michelle philippe
représentant boris godinov
drame musical populaire cataracte
avec et prologue
pouchkine
george dawg
kaloff
robert massa
verlam louis nogueira
schwisky georgie
jour
étranger
original
étranger étranger
étranger
oh
est
ah euh hey
moi
mon
oh
étranger
bonjour uh uh uh
double
is
hmm
please
lose
here
is
donc
les arbres
c'est
tellement
oh
alors
euh
c'est euh
tellement
bonjour
hé l'
étranger
est
tony
oui
étranger euh
tellement tellement bonjour
est euh étranger hey euh oh oh
faux c'est oh
tu vois
dimitri
oh
l'
étranger
est
l'
étranger
est
aussi
était
oh
mon
courir
le plaisir étranger se
répandre
est-ce que
tu es
étranger
oh
jésus
étranger
moi
oui
tu vois
alarme étrangère étranger
oreilles étrangères
vrai
était
étranger
nous sommes
certainement
étrangers oh
ici étranger étranger étranger étranger
nous
s'il vous plaît
étranger
oh
mon
plus
si
gregory
oh
oh étranger étranger
étranger
oh
frontière
hmm étranger étranger étranger
oh
moi
pourquoi
étranger
l'étranger étranger étranger
m
étranger oh
oui s'il te plait
étranger au revoir
viens oh
est
étranger étranger étranger étranger étranger
étranger
hôtel étranger
est
dieu moi étranger
étranger
est
est euh
étranger dis moi
alors
oh
moi
étranger
m
loin
est
dire
savoir
oh
amour étranger étranger
étranger
oh étranger étranger s'il vous
plaît
bleu oh étranger étranger étranger
était oh
votre téléphone
voyez
oh
étranger
oh étranger
tout
est
ce qui est
un
oh
m
cette terre
est une
cavité
nous étranger
d'accord
moi
étranger étranger
étranger
étranger grâce étrangère doux étranger étranger étranger
est étranger
whisky étranger
seigneur hé étranger étranger je étranger est
nous sommes
moi
oh
étranger
facial euh
toi oh
um
chien étranger
oui euh
étranger
mon
oh
étranger
est  euh bonjour
oui
oh
étranger étranger
maman étranger étranger étranger
oh
étranger
est
étranger étranger
films étrangers
alors
oh
étranger
étranger donc
monsieur
nous
la terre
de l'
étranger oh oh oh oh
sony
expérience senior
euh
tellement
plainte
non
étranger
est
oui
oh
étranger
de quoi de
neuf
est
oh est
étranger
garçon étranger étranger étranger
oh oh uh uh oh est oh oh
est oh
ouais étranger
pieds étrangers de l'âme
est oh oh oh
est oh
uh uh
recyclage étranger
oh
seigneur
mon
oh
moi
donc
oui
michel filippo